- All right, thank you very
much everyone for coming.
Today we're gonna talk about a topic
that was barely discussed this conference,
and kind of under the headlines,
we're gonna talk about AI.
But seriously now,
I think one of the areas
where AI can make the biggest
impact is observability.
And observability is one
of the closer areas to code
where AI is already making
a huge impact in the world
and it's actually has the potential
to not just make our lives easier
as software engineers
and platform engineers,
but also make our lives better
with faster, better software delivery,
better stability and security of software.
When we thought about it in Coralogix,
we were trying to understand
what is the highest value
that we can provide.
Is it an assistant?
Is it a co-pilot?
And we came up with Olly.
This session is going to be both
about how we built it
and how we came to that conclusion
of what exactly is going to be the design,
but also a bit about how you
guys can build it on your own,
and what are the
fundamentals that you need
to build an AI agent,
not just for observability by the way,
but for any data access.
I'll start with a bit of background
about Coralogix and ourselves.
I'm the co-founder, CEO of Coralogix.
Liran heads AI for Coralogix right here.
He'll be the one talking more about Olly.
We started Coralogix in 2015,
launched in 2017,
over 300 petabytes of data ingested
every day in the Coralogix.
Probably a much bigger number.
We raised about $400 million so far,
running multi-cloud,
but primarily Amazon.
Coralogix also was awarded this year
EMEA Partner of the year
for Amazon Marketplace.
And we run on eight
different regions today,
including the federal
cloud on FedRAMP Moderate.
I don't have to say much.
Software is complex and it's
getting more and more complex.
Actually, this thing,
sometimes you need to use
something that you edited or something.
This is like a small company service map.
When we look at large scale companies,
services got so complex today,
it's almost impossible
for a platform engineer.
And I think it also reflected in culture
of push things towards the engineering
and the service owners,
just because it's impossible to understand
and grasp software systems today.
If we go back in time
when we kind of started
our engineering experience,
maybe 15, 17 years ago,
not not several decades ago,
there were monoliths.
You would go to the machine,
you'd look at the logs,
maybe a little bit of metrics.
You get a good understanding
of what's happening.
These days with microservices,
different deployment models,
multi-cloud, serverless,
your ability to actually understand
what's happening in your
software is very limited.
And we think we have the solution to that,
but we'll talk about it in a minute.
Telemetry is exploding.
So people think, okay,
how do I monitor all these microservices?
How do I get a better understanding
of what's happening in
my production systems?
I'm just gonna add more telemetry.
I'm gonna add a metric,
I'm gonna add a log.
I'm gonna add another instrumentation.
And just over eight years, we see a 100X.
This is from public sources,
100X increase in telemetry data.
What does it mean?
It means that it's complex,
it means that it's expensive,
it means that it's difficult to manage,
but we're not really getting
better observability.
And we'll talk about that.
The solution is the all-in-one dashboard.
One dashboard, it has all that you need,
all the KPIs that you're tracking.
I'm of course joking.
The last thing we need
is another dashboard.
The last thing we need is another alert.
The world of just dashboarding everything
and alerting on every single
possible scenario removes
a bit of the ownership
from the service owners
and engineers towards the services
that they provide and run in production.
We think, okay, we solve the
problem, we add a dashboard.
What's our definition
of done for a feature?
We have dashboards and alerts set for it.
But the definition of
done for a feature is
that we can run it in production
and keep it in high quality
and high performance.
So that led us to build
more dashboards and alerts
and it feels like we got good coverage.
This is an average of
a Coralogix customer.
I'm talking only the dashboards
that are accessed and
alerts that are triggered.
We're in the hundreds.
Sometimes we come to customers
that have 10,000 alerts, 20,000 alerts.
Can you really comprehend the system?
Do you really own your service
if it triggers 20 alerts every day
and has 100 dashboards on it?
Probably not.
This is what it'll look like.
You go into your dashboard interface,
you got multiple folders.
Many things are just, you
know, duplicated variables
that you need to change to understand
your specific component.
Hundreds of alerts that are triggered.
And then we built on top these alerts,
we built all these alert aggregation tools
and incident management tools.
So we're trying to figure out the problem,
but we started with a
very kind of low state
and we're trying to improve it.
There's a paradigm now
where more dashboards,
more data, more alerts don't
mean more observability,
don't mean more reliability.
And intuitively, you'd imagine
on data analytics in general,
you know, and a lot of us
studied math or statistics,
the more data you have,
the more accurate you are.
The more data points you get,
the better insights you get.
In reality, if you think about this
for observability in
software, what is easier?
Is it easier debugging a
service with one service,
a gigabyte of logs every day,
and 100 custom metrics
or billions of metrics,
terabytes of data for multiple services?
Obviously, it's easier when you have less.
So how do we deal with that?
Do we build more dashboards?
Do we create more alerts?
Do we trim down data,
which is also a complete industry
that's started now just
for filtering data out.
We got so much garbage,
we don't wanna pay for it.
We start filtering out,
we start optimizing.
And
the numbers I've given
on dashboards and alerts,
those are only the ones
that are being accessed.
92% of dashboards are
only used for one week.
People will create kind
of a standalone dashboard
for a specific issue they have,
then they neglect it.
Now the funny part is,
you know what's gonna happen
in the next postmortem?
The conclusions are we're
gonna add this dashboard now
and alert,
so next time we'll know.
But they, you just go back and add
the same dashboard a week later.
No one looks at it.
So engineers now have to spend
close to half their time just
triaging and understanding
where should I even look?
What dashboard do I need to look at
out of 100 alerts?
And every time there's a big incident
in large scale systems and you know,
we run one, coincidentally,
when one service goes wrong,
everyone starts firing alerts and errors.
So where do I even start?
A lot of the times we start
triaging and we think,
oh, it's that service.
No, this is just downstream.
This is just the upstream.
So can we do something better?
Is there a way to deal with this?
And also a big question is,
how come this wasn't solved yet?
It's a big problem and the data grows
faster than our ability to deal with it.
Now there's an opportunity
because something big
happened in technology
over the past few years,
and how do we leverage that?
So let's start with the basics.
Observability is a term
that we have a problem with,
to be frank.
And it's a bit of a,
it's a bit tricky because
we're an observability company,
but observe is a very passive term.
Do I want to observe my systems?
I mean, imagine police officers will say
that their job is to observe the street.
We're actually, you know,
we need to keep systems
up and running.
We don't need to observe them.
Having more monitors and
dashboards and telemetry is
a great way to observe,
but what's the end goal?
The end goal is to have reliability,
to have stability, to
create business insights,
to have security.
So we keep building better observability,
but we kind of forgot
why we're building it.
And you know, I can say that Coralogix,
specifically, Coralogix had invested
over $250 million in R&D
over the past six years.
So imagine the amount of
engineering and R&D work
that we put in just try to keep up
with how fast data and
systems were evolving.
So we were in that arms race
against obviously a very crowded space,
but it was very hard for us
to go back to the essence
of what companies want,
which is reliability, ease of management,
being able to resolve issues faster,
have performance that's measurable,
actually meet business KPIs
that drive the revenue of the business
and the customer satisfaction.
Now how do we get there?
Every software emits
millions and trillions
sometimes of data points.
Coralogix cover the entire suite,
whether it's logs, metrics, traces,
infra monitoring, APM, realism monitoring,
SIM, AI monitoring.
So, we have enough signals.
We can get signals for
every user action now.
But the challenge is
how do we stitch 'em together
into a story and the cardinality of data
and the variety of data
and the multidimensional
aspect of it creates
such anthropy that to actually understand
what are the connections in a way
that gives me high
certainty to take action is
really complex.
And the compute that it required
until now was just impossible to employ,
to solve that problem.
And the data was growing so fast.
So that frog leap we've made
in technology now enables something else.
How do we now create a story,
not, we don't have an assistant
to help you build another
dashboard or you know,
a co-pilot that gives you hints.
How do we autonomously
and automatically create
that story from those breadcrumbs
to create a complete new interface,
a complete new approach to observability
and go back to the basics of
simple and coherent insights
that lead to reliability,
performance, business KPIs.
And there comes Olly,
and I'll hand it to Liran.
- Thank you, Ariel.
So as Ariel mentioned,
we've been focusing on the wrong thing
for the past few years, right?
We have been focusing
about how we do better
observability and we forgot why.
We forgot that the key,
the end goal we are
actually aiming for, right?
Is just to have reliable software.
We built something, we invested
in developing a software,
we wanted our users to
experience something
and we built crazy platforms
just to observe them.
And yes, we have very,
very advanced tools,
but how much do we increase reliability?
How much have we increased reliability
with all these capabilities?
And this new paradigm of AI, right?
Like I think you can see it here
on every single booth
and every vendor, right?
There's a true and great power to it,
which allows us really to rethink
what is observability or,
you know, really reliability.
How do we achieve it
and how can we actually
do it not the same way,
not grow linearly,
but actually how can we
do it 10 times better
than what we've done until now?
And this is where Olly
comes into the picture,
the world first autonomous
observability agent.
So what Olly is doing?
How it actually works, right?
So we talked about billions
and trillions of breadcrumbs,
logs, metrics, traces.
Let's say I'm at home watching Netflix,
watching "Squid Games",
I click on episode number two
and it doesn't work right?
Or it glitches for a few seconds, right?
Quite annoying.
Not a fun evening to have,
but why it happens?
So it means there's probably
something along the way
along the software stack, right?
Maybe some microservice backend,
maybe a database experiencing some issues,
maybe actually another
third party application
that my app, that Netflix app is
connected through API,
having some, experiencing
some issues, right?
And all these pieces somehow result
in me as a user experiencing
not even a downtime,
just a glitch or unexpected behavior
that what the original
engineers actually wanted
and aimed for.
So this, all these pieces,
taking these, each and every component,
the microservices, the databases,
the Lambda functions,
taking the breadcrumbs
of each one of them potentially
should tell a story of what happened
to Liran as a user, right?
And the question is not only
what happened to me personally
as a user,
but what actually happens
as a trend for more users.
Maybe there are hundreds
or thousands users
experiencing the same issue
and what's common about all of them.
So back to what we see on the screen,
we see all these billions
of breadcrumbs, right?
And usually, how do we do it?
We open the alerts,
try to find correlated alerts,
we deep dive into the dashboard,
we filter out for logs, we say,
"Hey, I see there's
some error logs," right?
And then I understand, oh I see
like this services seems
to be related, right?
So I further analyze.
So we have logs, we have,
sorry, we have alerts,
we have dashboards.
And the third component
is plenty of manual labor
going into resolving,
investigating production incidents, okay?
So with Olly,
we have all this information
available not only for us
but also for Olly.
And the beauty of it is that
it makes everything go away.
No, okay,
so Olly takes all this information,
we can give them the task
and then it zooms in
onto out of all these
billions of breadcrumbs,
onto the specific, most relevant pieces
to the task at hand.
And the next thing, it actually
eliminates the noise, right?
Remember we have more and
more and more and more,
we lost clarity, we got more noise,
Olly eliminates all this noise
and can actually focuses on the signals
that truly are important
and hopefully will tell
my story as a user.
And most importantly,
it can connect the dots
to one single story,
what the end user is experiencing
or the end users are experiencing
all the way back to what was
the root cause of that?
Sounds too good to be true.
Yes, no, okay.
So yeah, these are nice slides,
but I think the proof is in the pudding.
So let's see Olly in the works.
So
what I'm going to do now,
you can see my screen right?
Awesome.
So, nice to meet you.
I'm Adam, I'm head of
platform at Sportify,
a sport goods companies
and I manage the e-commerce website
and the platform team.
And I'm just writing code in the meantime,
doing my day-to-day tasks.
And as I'm doing my work,
let's see,
oh, I got a message.
I got a message from Sarah Parks.
Let's see,
so Sarah is our VP of Product.
She's very good at what she's doing.
And let me zoom in a bit.
I got a message, Adam,
this doesn't look good.
What's going on?
We're getting slammed with
customers' complaints,
and seems like she
referred here to an alert
we got on production alert channel.
So let's take a deeper look into it.
So we can see a warning
about checkout error spike.
So we're an e-commerce website,
obviously the last part
is customers come in
after they chose the
items they can check out
and make the purchase.
And it seems like there is an issue.
So instead of opening another dashboard,
let me just ask Olly,
hey Olly, can you please take a look?
Okay, and as I tagged Olly,
Olly immediately reacted as you can see,
and it starts conducting
an investigation of what really happened.
And it shared with me this link
so I can see really what's
going on in real time.
Let me zoom in a bit,
okay,
so how will it work?
What we're actually seeing?
Olly works like yet another
engineer in your team.
So think about yourself, right?
You would've looked on
dashboard every time.
Let's say we would've
filtered for error logs,
we would've identified some pattern.
Actually, let me zoom out.
We would identify a pattern based on that.
We would probably see another
filter or go to traces, right?
Or go to metrics.
So in every given point in time,
I have one thing on my screen.
So on the right side, what you can see is
what Olly is currently looking at.
So for example, right now we can see
Olly is looking at the logs, okay?
And it's writing to me,
it's sharing with us
what it currently thinks and
what path it is exploring.
And it has many capabilities,
whether it's exploring logs, metrics,
traces, correlating them,
analyzing the code and more, okay?
And we see that we got a result,
so let's see what happened.
So let me close this.
And by the way, as you can
see this is a live demo.
Decided not to go for a video, okay?
So let's see.
I noticed a spike in failed checkouts
over the last two hours.
Dug into shopping cart API,
this is one of our services,
logs and found a new type error
that correlates exactly with the spike.
It is affecting about 2,000 users.
From here, we can see
what is the root cause,
failed checkouts are caused
by type error exceptions
in the shopping cart API service.
Now one more thing you
will see with Olly is
that every time Olly provides
you with information,
it backs it up with evidence.
Why?
Because we know AI can hallucinate,
can make up things
and we wanna make sure we
can actually trust Olly.
This is a key that we put
a lot, a lot of effort
and engineering resources into
ensuring the quality of Olly.
So I can see exactly the
logs that are relevant.
Let me open one of them
and we can see the message here is
unsupported operand
type and the trace back,
this is a pipe service.
So I can see really what's going on.
Let's go on.
So, where it crashes.
So Olly here actually opens the code file,
analyzed it and found the
specific lines of code
causing the issue.
It explains that some function failed
because it tried to add
interesting and none,
raising this error.
Why have we gotten to
this case from the get go
that we have none in this
list of items in Python?
The reason is bug in remove
from cart lines 65 to 66,
I can open the source file
and actually I also got
suggested fix from Olly.
So it seems, you know,
not like, really quite an easy fix.
We hopefully can apply.
Also an analysis of how
many users were impacted
and chart analyzing where
the issue has started,
how it looks like and so on.
Olly also share with you what happened.
So just to understand
how Olly really got to
this thing, it's not magic.
There was a real, in-depth
investigation that happened
in this one minute.
So Olly analyzed metrics,
it tried to find relevant metrics,
it looks specific payment errors, API
or checkout our account,
ran query, I won't go in
into each one of them,
but you can see just this,
let's say, see, we have
one, two, three, four,
four queries.
Just think about how
long would it take you
just to realize you
need to write this query
and filter this out and make
sure the syntax is correct
and realize what's the
insights you're getting from it
and how you can actually
continue with the investigation.
Usually, usually from what we see
in our customers this time being saved is
about 94% on average.
And to make it into
numbers, that means an issue
that would take me five
hours to investigate
with Olly would take
about 20 minutes, okay?
Obviously this is average,
there are things that finish
up in a matter of two minutes.
Some of them take longer than that.
But all in all, this
is extremely powerful.
Okay, so now we have the,
we've identified the issue.
Let me go back because I don't want
Sarah to be upset with me.
So Nikesh, our engineering lead,
hey, Nikesh, we have production issue.
Please take a look
on the reason
and deploy a fix ASAP.
Please keep me posted.
And I'll be sharing, let me go to Olly,
share, let share this link.
Awesome, and let's link Sarah,
we don't want to leave her waiting.
Sarah, thanks for bringing this up.
We're on it
and the fix is on the way.
I think it deserves some applause.
(audience applauds)
This is real, okay?
Like, this is real.
I have a video demo here
in case the internet would, you know,
make up some challenges.
But what you just saw, the
querying, the data, the use case,
all of this is from a
real environment, okay?
No, not a simulation
or anything like that.
So what we've just,
what we just saw,
this is not better observability.
This is how we can actually achieve
10 times better reliability
than what we had until now, okay?
Olly understands your stack,
this is super important.
The reason Olly was able to do that
in a matter of a minute
and come up with valuable insight
and not just made up ones is
because like similar to any engineer
you would hire that would
go through training,
when you connect and integrate
Olly for the very first time,
it learns your observability workspace,
it learns which applications you have,
what subsystems,
what fields are present
in the logs metrics.
Has it occurred to you
that you have five metrics,
one with capital case,
one with lower case,
they all mean the same thing
but they have different naming.
So when you query, you may
miss some of them, right?
Because you just didn't know
that the casing is so important.
So Olly familiar with all these fields
and this is extremely powerful.
This is what allows Olly really to conduct
smart and insightful investigations.
So in a matter of minute
we found the root cause,
we got the suggestion for a fix.
I think this example is
particularly interesting
because the fix here was not,
I dunno, increase CPU
or anything like that
or allocate more pods.
This actually was a code issue.
And think about an on-call.
Any on-call, any SRE, any developer,
doesn't matter how much experts they are,
with this, they could have gotten
to the root cause within
the lines of the code,
even if they're not familiar
and they haven't seen this
code repository before, okay?
So this is really the true
power we're talking about.
And I think most importantly,
I didn't open even one dashboard.
I didn't filter any query on my own
and this is really the true power
and the true potential we have here
to achieve 10 times better reliability.
Now for those of you here in the crowd,
and I see you, some
skeptical guys here thinking,
oh yeah, it's just
ChatGPT for observability,
it's, you know, I saw that.
It's not, okay?
And let me elaborate what Olly is not.
So it's not ChatGPT for observability
in the sense that Olly is not
just ChatGPT-like interface
for accessing your observability data.
It's not that.
Olly has context, Olly has knowledge.
Olly is autonomous,
meaning in every single,
he doesn't have playbooks.
In every single point of time, it decides
autonomously what is the next step?
Olly is also not an AI assistant.
Now I'm sure you saw plenty,
every single company
on earth these days got
directive from the CEO,
we need to add AI, as much
AI as possible, right?
So we see that with AI assistant,
this small, cute chatbot you see
on the bottom right usually, right?
Like, hey let me help you.
And these are great, like they
do provide a lot of value,
but the value they focus on is
really making you and making your users
more efficient within the platform, right?
So if Olly, for example, was an assistant,
it wouldn't do all the
investigation for you or with you,
it would actually just help you build
dashboard in Coralogix.
So it doesn't do that.
It's not an AI assistant.
The the difference in power
is not becoming, I dunno,
20% faster in building
dashboards or alerts.
It's actually becoming 10
times better in reliability,
which is a much broader, higher level goal
for the organization.
And lastly, MCP,
MCP has been around for quite a while now.
So Olly is not an MCP server.
We do offer MCP for Coralogix, okay?
But Olly is not that.
What's the differences?
MCP in a way is exposing API
for AI agents, okay?
So if I want to take my information
for example for to expose
Coralogix information
to other AI agents like Cursor,
I would take the Coralogix MCP server.
But it does not have any knowledge,
it does not have any special context.
It is not an AI agent, AI system.
So let's understand what
Olly is and how Olly works.
So it all starts with data.
For years, we've been really focused
around how we achieve, store better data.
And finally, I think really over a decade
that we're talking about data
and the potential value of data,
I think finally we can harness
the true value and the
true potential of data.
So Coralogix is really good
as a platform for processing,
harnessing tons, massive amounts of data,
petabytes of data, terabytes of data
that we've really close
to infinite retention.
So all of this is being leveraged by Olly.
Olly learns from this data,
creating a knowledge base,
like you would learn something
in school for example.
And then with this knowledge,
what he saw and saying that he may say,
hey, this is an AI, an
observability agent.
It is not observability agent
because agent is singular.
Behind the scenes, Olly
has a team of agents,
specialized agents working for you, okay?
So we have for example logs explorer,
we have metrics analyzer.
Each one of them is powered by SLMs.
SLMs are small language models,
think about 7 billion parameters,
13 billion parameters,
that is specialized in the specific role
and specific task at hand.
And they all collaborate
together to produce
insights, answers,
which all together allow us to get
this 10 times better reliability
we were talking about.
Now let's go a step back and talk
in general about any agentic AI system.
I think this is if you want to know
what you can take back
home to your offices,
to your work and how do
you build your AI agent
or your own Olly,
this is all about that.
So any agentic AI system
has five main components.
Obviously we can break it down to more,
but these are the core concepts
and the core things you must
have in agentic AI system.
So it starts with a model
in the center, okay?
Which is clear, this is like the engine
for our agent or our agentic system.
We have the system prompt.
So for example, you are an
expert in analyzing logs
for this company.
So this is how we provide
actual instructions to our agent.
Then we talked about multiple agents.
So we said logs explorer, right?
Metrics analyzer, let's say
security analyst and so on.
The way they collaborate
together could be different
and is crucial.
So for example, there are
different design patterns for it.
One architecture would be that I have
one orchestrator that takes the task.
For example, in this case
we ask for investigation.
So the orchestrator is familiar
with all the other
agents and assign tasks,
hey logs explorer, please find me
relevant logs to this issue.
Log explorer will come back with results,
orchestrator will decide on next steps.
This is one type,
another type is handovers.
We can decide, we can make
any sub-agent autonomous
so they can play around together as a team
like playing ball.
And at every given point in time,
someone else holds the ball,
meaning they are the one
leading the conversation from now on.
So there are different architectures
about how we actually organize our agents.
Then we have the knowledge,
which talks about really
how we provide this,
how we empower this agentic AI system
not only with tools
but also the knowledge,
the information that's
very, very much needed
to make smart decisions, smart actions.
And lastly but probably the
most important one is the evals,
how do we actually evaluate
the quality of our agentic system?
So out of these five,
what you will notice is model
is commodity, okay?
So Opus was released I think
a week ago or two weeks ago.
We have access to it, all
of you have access to it.
GPT5 got released, same thing.
So there's nothing really
unique about the model.
We can, we all share the same models,
and same for system prompt.
I can write something,
you can write something,
it won't make a huge, huge difference.
So that leaves us with
three other main components
which together compose what we call
the context engineering triangle.
The context engineering
triangle, this is the key.
What you see here, these three components,
if you want to build
powerful, high quality agent,
you need these three items
and you need to understand
them deeply and focus on them.
So we covered about agent architecture
and the importance of agent architecture.
I wanna talk a little bit
about knowledge and memory.
So in ChatGPT, I think we are all familiar
with the fact that as
we talk with ChatGPT,
sometimes it memorizes
what we talked with them
about it, right?
And then it can be reused
in other conversations.
But one of the challenges
with making agentic AI system
really, really good
with knowledge as well is
the limitation of context, right?
In theory, if I could take
all my petabytes of observability data
from the last week and just push it
to all of them and wish them good luck,
I will do that.
But it's not technically
possible as for today.
And I think we can also
take here the more is
not more here as well.
The fact that I will have more data
does not mean I will get better answers.
So what we do need?
We need to have relevant data,
we need to have it in a structured way
that is optimized for the LLM.
And let me tell you that it may sound
that changing models is quite easy, right?
Just within the API
call, change the string.
Hey, GPT5.
Now I want to use Claude, very easy.
In reality, changing model is difficult.
The reason it's difficult,
because different models has
different preferences
and you need to optimize
the context you're building accordingly.
So the knowledge needs
to be optimized as well.
So going back to we wanna build
this observability AI agent,
we need to push relevant
information to the context
and we already agreed
we cannot just take all
the logs, metrics, traces
and so on from the last week.
So we need really what,
the way to do it is
actually same way as we investigate
and as we conduct an investigation,
is identify the key parts
and the key elements,
store them at first.
And the structure rate could be
whether in vector DB, knowledge graph
or just rational DB depending
on what information we store,
and allow our agent to
access this information.
And the querying part is also key here
because the fact that I
have this information stored
somewhere does not mean
I know how to query in an effective way.
So we said how do we,
how do I store this information?
How do I structure it and how do I query?
These are the three components
when come to knowledge
and how we build this context.
So let's say we've done these
two really, really good.
So we have model, we have system prompt,
we have some agents architecture,
we can do something simple for starters.
And let's say I saved
some basic aggregations
on my log to start simple.
The last thing,
which is actually the most
important one, is evals.
Evals is short for evaluation.
Now in traditional software,
we have unit testing,
integration testing,
system testing, right?
When we build it, we test,
we see hey, thumbs up,
nothing broke, all good,
we can go live.
A new feature comes in,
we implement it, right?
We build some new tests, run
it again, all works well.
Ideally, we would've done
the same with AI agents.
The challenge though is
that there is no structure.
What are we testing, right?
Like we have a conversation,
the user can input whatever they want.
The possibilities are infinite, right?
Like, what do I test?
What happens if the user
just come in and say,
"Hey what should I
order for lunch", right?
Like there are infinite
amounts of possibilities
to what the user would put in.
So the question of how do I evaluate it
becomes really, really challenging.
And if not done correctly,
or if you actually build an AI agent
and you don't evaluate it at all,
I can show from experience what happens is
you build something, it
seems to be working right?
Even you, let's say you're very proud,
you deploy it to production,
you say to your friends,
"Hey, I have it.
You can start using it."
In a matter of minutes probably,
you will get some Slack message
or someone will tell you,
"Hey, hey look, I tried
this, it doesn't work."
So yeah, oh, no problem, I'm on it.
You'll go back, you'll check
this very, very specific use case
and you'll change the system prompt.
And guess what?
You will be successful in
resolving this use case.
So it seems like we made progress,
but what you didn't realize is
as you change the system prompt,
you change the entire
behavior of the agent.
So things that used to work before,
the test that you ran a day ago,
this use case is not
working anymore, okay?
So this is why evaluations
in AI agents are
no less than crucial.
I will say just one
more thing about evals,
another challenge here is
not only testing because
it's not just one message.
I got input, output is it correct or not?
We have an entire flow of conversations.
So how do we test this?
So I'll leave it as a food for thought
and we can talk this offline
if some of you are interested.
So how does that translate into Olly?
So the beautiful thing you saw before,
this is what happens behind the scenes.
Onto the left, okay?
And this is really sharing
with you the internals,
how Olly works under the hood.
On the left, Olly is
powered by Coralogix's
extremely powerful observability
data platform, okay?
So notice, remember I told you
Olly is not an AI assistant.
That's exactly that.
Olly is not an expert in using Coralogix
or using its feature to build dashboards.
It is an expert in
helping you with achieving
better reliability and
investigating issues,
optimizing production and so on.
So it leverages the large scale
data observability platform
by Coralogix.
From it, it takes all these signals
and creates knowledge.
To be honest, like if you
would ask me to choose
one thing
or the key to all these
success and quality lies,
it's within the knowledge.
And then we have the collaboration
of the multiple agents,
again, each one powered
by small language model,
which allows us to get really
invaluable production insight,
as we saw.
So how can you take it back home
and how can you start build your own Olly?
So first thing first, data.
We need to store all
of our data somewhere,
logs, metrics, traces.
The more we have, the better.
But we also need to make sure
that we build in a structured way
that the agent can
actually optimize in that.
The second part is what we call
semantic layer, okay?
Semantic layer is really a more,
we call it a basic understanding
at least of the data.
Let's say I have a field that has
name CPU USG 7D.
What does that mean?
So maybe we can assume it means CPU usage
over the last seven days,
whatever is CPU usage
over the last seven days.
But it's important for
the agent, for the LLM,
for our engine to have this information
because this what allow the agent to make
smart decisions.
Say "Hey, I have a problem with CPU,"
this metric is actually
the metric that would,
is likely to be relevant.
So maybe I should check this out.
Okay, so semantic layer is,
I would call it kind of
the first building block
within the knowledge of the agent.
And the third part is
building your first AI agent MVP,
take whatever model, build it.
There are actually great tools,
whether it's OpenAI agents at Python SDK,
LangChain and others,
today it became quite easy
to come up with an MVP.
So I do recommend really
just getting your hands on
and try to build this thing.
So, and this is, you know,
just the core concept to start with.
So from here,
we've seen one demonstration
of how Olly works.
Olly has been in beta
for the last few months with
some of Coralogix's customers.
I do wanna share with
you how it actually work,
how it actually looks in real life.
So this is a story of
one of our customers.
I was actually fascinated to hear that,
to be honest.
So they had a notification service, okay?
It's a microservice running on Docker
that had random latency
spikes every now and then.
It was really unclear what's going on.
They look on the logs,
they look on the metrics,
they look on the traces,
they try to analyze them,
but they couldn't find any correlation
to these latency spikes.
They were really puzzled
of what's going on.
And at some point they say, you know what?
We have no idea.
So, let's leave it this way.
After trying out Olly for a few weeks,
they say, you know what?
Let's give it a try, we
have nothing to lose, right?
So what happened?
Okay, so the first thing that
Olly helped them realize is
this notification service is
actually connected to
another email service
that's connected to authentication service
that's using RDS.
Now that's interesting because
until that point in time,
they didn't even think or consider
checking for RDS
because the service itself has
nothing related to RDS, okay?
So they were looking in the wrong places.
Now, not only that it is connected to RDS,
the reason it is interesting
as Olly identified,
Olly correlated spikes in the CPU,
CPU spikes of the RDS,
amount of connections,
as well as latency spikes of the RDS.
And this was correlated with the spikes
of the notification service.
So for the very first
time after four months,
they got some clue of,
we have at least more
understanding of what's going on.
Now, the investigation didn't stop there.
It was not the one shot,
it was not just one prompt there,
it was four or five messages
in the conversation.
So the next thing that
Olly shared with them,
it has found another Lambda function
that also works with this RDS function.
Oh, sorry, with this RDS database.
And the interesting thing is that
this Lambda database,
sorry, this Lambda function apparently has
also correlation when it activates
with the spikes of the Postgres, okay?
And looking, when Olly
looked on the queries
that were running by this Lambda function,
it realizes this,
that the queries were running against
unindexed tables, right?
Which obviously makes,
creates loads on the RDS
and as a result, identification service.
So from here, the fix was quite obvious.
Olly also recommended it,
but I think it was quite clear
that the fix is really
just building indexes
for these tables.
But this is fascinating.
Like, think about how much time
would take to find and investigate
and get to the root cause of
something like that, right?
We have three services,
one Lambda function,
each one running and being
managed by a different team.
RDS didn't even think about it
as something that could be related.
And in general, something tricky
about Lambda functions, right?
They start, they end, nothing happened,
like they never existed.
So this is a real case, super interesting,
four months this issue was unsolved,
tried with Olly less than 10 minutes,
they realize what's going on.
So we talked about the
power of reliability,
we talked about the fact
that our focus was in the wrong place.
We are running after observability,
we forgot to chase after reliability.
So how do we move from here?
Okay, we're still in the early days of AI
and what you see?
So in the last decade,
I would say observability has increased
and has
kind of evolved in a linear way.
We've had the more features,
we've had user sessions,
run more capabilities,
obviously, more features.
So we have improved but not exponentially.
This is the first step.
What I'm just presenting you, okay,
this is just the first
step in a paradigm shift
we're experiencing.
The first milestone is co-pilot, okay?
So just to clarify, it's
not here to replace anyone,
it's here to help us make
our work, make our job
much, much better
and to allow us to focus
on what really matters.
The next step for Olly,
and by the way, it's like few weeks
from getting the first release of it,
is being proactive.
What does that mean?
It means two things.
One, it means when an
alert fires on Slack,
Olly automatically triage and provide you
with initial understanding
of what's going on.
The second part of being proactive is
really allowing Olly to
take actions, all right?
Maybe it's suggest pull request.
Maybe it's suggest changing
our AWS environment.
So this is the next step,
this is the proactive phase
and the holy or Olly grail is
getting to preventive observability, okay?
Now think about it.
This is an ideal,
think about an agent and I
think we've been talking about
this vision for years now,
but for the very first time it seems
possible to get to a point
where we have an agent
that constantly watches our production.
Whether it's from product standpoint,
whether it's from cost standpoint,
operations, infrastructure
and so on and so forth.
It is familiar with the
way it works in general,
it is familiar with seasonality
and can say, hey, listen,
we expect to see increase in
load in the next few days.
We have 80% utilization.
We have to increase the amount of pods
and take action and actually increase
these amount of pods,
preventing a downtime or delay for users.
So this is really where
we are going with that.
And with that, I'm really happy to share
that Olly is now generally available
for all of Coralogix's customers.
We started rolling this
out and by December 15th,
will be publicly available
for all of our users.
So,
I think we covered a lot of points,
whether it's the fact that the
software stack has changed.
I really remember, you know, 10 years ago
when you build an app,
it was just one single application.
It was web application,
you were running it on one
web server and that's it.
And maybe, you know, you had
some blogs written somewhere
to help you debug it.
So it was much, much, much
easier, much convenient.
But now we have microservices
and we have serverless and
we have so many tech stack
and so many moving parts,
all of them creating so many breadcrumbs.
So we have to find a better way
to achieve software reliability.
This is not a feature,
Olly, autonomous observability,
this is not a feature.
It's not just something cool,
it's really a paradigm shift.
It's really a change of the way we think,
the way we work, the way we act.
And the time is now.
It is not something futuristic.
What you saw is already working,
proactive is really, let's
say two, three months away.
So the time to adopt this solution,
the time to implement those solutions is
really now, okay?
We have this opportunity
to make our software
much, much better, to
make our work better.
And with that, I want to thank you.
I'm happy to take questions afterwards.
I'm not sure if we have time.
- [Ariel] Yeah, just we got
like a few minutes for questions
if anyone wants, we're very.